novembre 2016 des syndicalistes
agricoles plantes des croix devant le
salon ferme expo à tour une mise en
scène macabre mais justifié une semaine
plus tôt un éleveur laitier de
préfontaine près de montargis s'est
suicidé avec son fusil de chasse au beau
milieu de son village le papa qui
disparaît un moment qui est dans un
centre en prenne plein dépression cet
événement constitue un électrochoc pour
le président de la chambre d'agriculture
du loiret dans les semaines qui suivent
ils multiplient les interventions pour
sauver les exploitants en danger un plan
d'action toujours d'actualité est mis en
place pour éviter de nouveaux drames ont
fait un check up de l'entreprise donc ça
ça coûte rien c'est pris en charge à la
fois par le conseil départemental et la
chambre ces quatre heures d'entretiens
et avec ça on vous donne un plan
d'accompagnement pour un an et au bout
d'un an on vient vous revoir pour faire
un point de situation et le deuxième
dispositif qui peut paraître anecdotique
mais qui l'est pas c'est la possibilité
que la chambre a donné à tout
agriculteurs du département d' adhérer
gratuitement la première année à un
groupement de développement agricole
alors ça c'est effectivement un suivi
technico économique mais c'est surtout
le fait de rompre l isolement
l' isolement est aussi une préoccupation
de la msa la mutualité sociale agricole
devenu acteur numéro un dans la
prévention du suicide
en complément des chambres d'agriculture
la msa a déployé un dispositif de
détection des paysans en souffrance un
travail de terrain mené par des équipes
spécialisées
le binôme est constitué d'un d'une
assistante sociale donc de la msa et
d'un médecin du travail de la msa
donc on est plutôt au départ sur une
gestion administrative de la situation
c'est à dire on va regarder
est ce que la personne déjà à tous ses
droits légaux et plus derrière
d'orienter des situations faire défaire
des liens avec le médecin traitant
orientés vers des professionnels de
l'écouté ou même pourquoi pas orienter
vers des prises en charge
urgentes telles que le samu ça arrivait
de trois fois pour vraiment des
situations très urgente en 2017 ses
actions conjointes ont permis de
détecter 42 cas de mal être dans les
départements du berry et de la touraine
dans le même temps le loiret a procédé à
six en audit d'exploitation pour
proposer des solutions économiques et
financières les suicides d'agriculteurs
reste néanmoins une triste réalité en
on les estime toujours à plus de 160
parents